what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are covering the sins of sinister now
here's the thing to understand the sons
of sinister is a crossover event it is
nine issues long the first three issues
are year 10 the second three is year 100
and the final three is a year one
thousand now it doesn't really tie into
any existing X-Men Comics meaning it's
not sins of sinister X-Men number
whatever however we need to get caught
up on the X-Men so after we're done with
this we're gonna get caught back up
which is what we should have been doing
this whole time because I love the X-Men
but you can understand this without
knowing everything that's going on so
the first thing that happens here is
basically Sinister is dragged to the pit
of krakowa literally taken prisoner and
locked away now we don't need to know
everything that's going on in order to
understand the rest of this story
because honestly this is the least
interesting thing that happens this
story gets nuts but we will make sense
of why this happens once we go back and
start covering the various X-Men titles
and getting caught up one of the big
takeaways from all this is that after
this is done when you have Charles
Xavier if you're basically him removing
his helmet you end up finding out that
he's got a Sinister diamond on his head
now what this is designed to do is to
basically illustrate the idea that
Xavier himself is under the influence of
sinister but it's not even just
Professor Xavier Emma Frost Exodus hopes
Summers they're all under the influence
of sinister so we don't know exactly how
he did this we will find out in this
story but we don't know exactly how he
did this here in the moment the bigger
discussion that goes on here is the
question of what do they do now that the
seeds there's so many seeds in the quiet
Council are empty right the ruling
governing body of the X-Men on the
mutant island of krakowa now some of the
things that led to this we have already
covered so when you had like The Inferno
event where it turned out that Maury
McTaggart the one who would set all this
up in the first place that she had put
together the plan of krakowa and giving
mutants a safe haven because what she
wanted to do and having died and lived a
new life so many times she literally
always saw that no matter what half
happened there was always a war between
humans and mutants or humans and like
some alien race or something like that
but the mutant population was always
wiped out no matter what happened
mutants were always destroyed and so her
idea was that in order to keep that from
happening by having the quiet counsel
and the resurrection protocols and all
that kind of stuff over time as
different X-Men were resurrected they'd
be resurrected without their powers and
that would lead to them being forced out
of krakowa and over time it would reduce
the number of mutants that exist in the
world hence the reason why krakawa was
presented as a safe haven for the
entirety of the mutant population
because it was a really simple and
elegant way for Mora to effectively
genetically remove mutants or at least
genetically remove the mutant Gene from
the human population therefore
preventing the end-all destruction of
the mutant population so it was pretty
wild and depending on where you stand
morally you may or may not agree with it
but of course at the end of that story
there were a few things going on one
Sinister of course is currently part of
the Quad counselor was until he was
taken away okay and again we'll get
caught up on why that happened but with
the events of Inferno and Maura
McTaggart that Destiny the mutant
precognitive the one who can basically
predict the future she and Mystique who
of course have been long time lovers in
Marvel Comics they left right so a lot
of these seats are empty here so the
discussion that's being asked by
Professor Xavier and Emma Frost and
these guys is why don't we fill these
seats with humans now for the most part
this is almost completely and totally
shut down by Exodus but he ends up
changing his mind once Hope Summers
agrees with it now this is not like
Exodus being a simp right I know some
people may have like that knee-jerk
reaction see without having any evidence
about the character whatsoever or
knowing nothing about his motivations
I've drawn a complete and total
unquestionable conclusion uh the reality
when it comes to Exodus if you've been
reading the X-Men for a while is that
he's not in love with hope the idea here
is that he sees hope as basically the
Messiah a god-like being and rightfully
so right it was with the birth of Hope
Summers in Marvel Comics that the X
X-Men or really mutants started to
return to Marvel Comics after the events
of House of M and destination when the
Scarlet Witch took away 98 of the mutant
population's Powers right effectively
wiped out most of the mutant population
and so when this is initially thrown out
there for the most part the quiet
household actually starts to agree with
it and the reason why is because what
they want to do is they want to
basically impose this way of Conquering
the world now we'll see how this unfolds
over the course of this because I'll be
honest with you guys it's a genius
strategy and it's a genius plan because
what they do here is by bringing human
beings onto the quiet Council one that
begins to quell the concern of different
governments out there about what the
mutants are up to by giving them a peek
on the inside of the island of kakawa
and in fact allowing them a seat on the
governing body it gives human beings the
illusion of control and so what we do is
we jump forward one year and we have
reporter Ben Urich meeting with Jay
Jonah Jameson from the Spider-Man comics
at the daily vehicle now now the funny
thing here is that Ben Uric is being
incredibly careful here right
exceedingly cautious and the reason for
this is that as he meets with Jay Jonah
Jameson he injects him with a kind of
chemical and what this does is it's
basically designed to see who is
infected with the X Gene that's
circulating around out there and who's
not and so what ends up happening is
that once it turns out that Jay Jonah
Jameson is seemingly his normal self
then York spills the beans on everything
that he's discovered and what he learned
is that when human beings were brought
onto the Kauai Council that what the
mutant population started doing was
handing out these different genes right
that could prolong life different things
like that kind of an upgraded version so
to speak of the different medicines and
stuff that cocoa had but what it
secretly did is it planted a gene inside
of the of human beings that would allow
them at any point in time to be
overtaken by the mutant population it's
a trojan horse and so when that happened
what you started seeing was that people
who were their normal selves but had the
gene which suddenly switch right a
switch would would kind of flick in
their head and they would become
basically an agent of the mutant
population really by extension an agent
of sinister sort of doing their own
thing or doing whatever it is they were
told to do and so that's literally when
Ben you're just like I mean I've spotted
that with a few people here and there
but I mean what if it's like politicians
right senators and congressmen
congresswomen right what do we do in
that kind of situation right some
dictator out there somewhere right
people who run entire countries could be
compromised and under control of the
mutant population and that's what we end
up finding out that Jay Jonah Jameson is
under control with the Sinister Gene
that the idea here is that the test that
was used by Ben Uric was a false test
that was leaked out there so that people
who were by and large looking at this as
a kind of Nefarious act would leap on
that opportunity to expose the truth to
the world it's a very very smart move
right just basically throw out a reel
add a little bit of bait and then bring
them in and then have them taken over by
the Gene and that's what happens with
Ben yurich it is to would agree if we're
being honest the plot to the film
um oh my God what is that movie with the
Invasion of the Body Snatchers that's
basically what this is to a degree and
so the bigger concern that they have
here is okay what do we do about the
mutant nation of kokoro right the living
Island what do we do about this right I
mean this is literally a living Island
that can at any point in time make the
entire environment inhospitable to us
right it can just start filling the air
with some kind of a toxic gas that can
kill us right it's like M Night
shyamalan's the happening right where
plants are killing people like that's
basically the concern they have so Forge
ends up inventing or creating this
cannon that can be fired from the from a
satellite that will basically lobotomize
uh krakowa and that's exactly what
happens they fire this cannon they take
out the mutant island of krakawa and
that's when the X-Men make their move
that Emma Frost telepathically
broadcasts to the world because one of
the things that the X-Men is sort of
built on is by saying by having this
Gene right telling Humanity if you have
this Gene that means we can back up you
and your loved ones this also comes out
of the events of Judgment Day right
that's when Humanity learned that the
X-Men had like the resurrection
protocols people were pissed off because
the X-Men basically had the ability to
bring the dead back to life with all
their memories and Humanity wanted that
that's what that's what the X-Men are
building on here and so that's when Emma
Frost broadcasts to the world so he says
the orcas space station right this group
that's been out there since the
beginning of Jonathan Hickman's run that
has been working against the meeting
population for a while think of them as
like the modern day interpretation of
like Friends of Humanity or like the
right or something like that right like
the purifiers to a degree but they
literally say like the orcas space
station has laid an attack against
krakowa and by attacking our Island
they've destroyed not only the backups
for us as X-Men but the backups for all
your human loved ones so we need to
strike back against the orcas station
literally they fabricate an attack and
use that as a as really an excuse to
wipe out their own enemy by having
everybody else come under this false
pretense and so literally what happens
here of course also Douglas Ramsey's
killed by Wolverine because Douglas
Ramsey can kind of figure out what's
going on right he's the one that talks
to the mutant island of krakowa but what
ends up happening here is under the
false pretense that orcas led the attack
that during this one year time Jump the
X-Men bring together the Avengers and a
whole host of other superheroes and
launch an attack against orcas now the
one thing that could stand in their way
and the one thing that could annihilate
all of them is Nimrod right the ultimate
Sentinel the machine that had the
ability to recognize their powers and
adapt to those Powers as well as use
their weaknesses so Tony Stark ends up
developing a virus or really along with
Reed Richards and Forge end up
developing a virus that infiltrates
Nimrod and takes Nimrod offline so he's
no longer part of the equation but all
of these guys are doing it under false
pretenses the X-Men are the only ones
who are aware of what's going on that
whole whole thing with like Ben Urich
and Jay Jonah Jameson it's all super
Hush Hush at the moment right nobody
really understands or realizes the X-Men
slowly starting to take over the world
and so in this meeting or in the
aftermath of this battle where you have
Cyclops talking to Captain America
Cyclops literally says cap it's awesome
to fight by you again right like you've
earned yourself a place as an honorary
X-Man which in this time and this in
this landscape when the X-Men are so
kind of cut off from the world that's a
huge honor well I just like being made
an honorary member of The Avengers like
40 years ago in Marvel Comics it's a big
deal and so Captain America of course
accepts the invitation Captain America
comes under the control of the X-Men and
so what ends up happening here is that
following all of this that Sinister is
brought back from the pits and now
Sinister is effectively sort of running
the show to a degree or at least kind of
enjoying everything that they're doing
what Sinister does is that while the
Kwai council is continuing their
campaign of essentially trying to take
over the world by infiltrating people
and turning them into what are basically
mind-controlled people Sinister ends up
going to his own private lab and what he
does in talking to the lab is he says
with everything going the way that it is
give me a projection on how things are
going to play out right give me a
projection on what the future of the
world is going to look like because of
all of this and this is when things get
really really cool so one of the first
things that happens is we end up
learning that Thanos will inevitably
launch another attack against Earth and
that he's actually just sort of
traveling through the time stream and so
what ends up happening is the Juggernaut
is shrunk down to a miniature size and
then Hope Summers borrows the powers of
domino which is important because Domino
has the ability to bend luck to her side
and so Hope Summers using basically the
ability to manipulate luck fires
Juggernaut from a cannon and because
once the Juggernaut starts moving he
cannot be stopped the Juggernaut
literally punches a hole through Thanos
and kills Thanos as he's moving through
the time stream now eventually
Juggernaut re-enters into the main
Universe After exiting the time stream
but is just continuing to fly out there
in a direction and nobody ever makes an
effort to go and get him so he's just
essentially flying towards the edge of
the universe where he'll ultimately
Droid following that Dr Doom ends up
figuring out what's going on with the
mutant population taking over the world
through mind control and he ends up
allying himself with name or the
Submariner because Neymar of course is
spewing a bunch of a bunch of
anti-mutant rhetoric what Victor Von
Doom doesn't know is that name of the
Submariner has been converted as well
and then it was all a ruse to get Victor
Von Doom on his side when that happens
he kills Dr Doom secretly right just
stabbing him with a trident and then
following that the Eternal start to
realize what's happening and so because
of the events at the end of Judgment Day
the peace treaty that was struck between
the X-Men and the eternals at the end of
the Judgment Day story is that the X-Men
would have control of Uranus right the
once ancient Eternal that was nigh
Unstoppable and was Unleashed during
that event and wiped out a huge portion
of the mutant population with Uranus
under their control in the Eternal X-Men
War the X-Men from basically all over
the place end up unleashing Uranus who
wipes out the entirety of the of the
Eternal now because the eternals
themselves can be resurrected in order
to prevent that from happening the
eternals are put in stasis and launched
into deep space so now they're no longer
part of the equation following that the
X-Men's attention turns to the Fantastic
Four and the concern is that because
Reed Richards is so intelligent if he
hasn't figured out what's going on right
now he inevitably will given his level
of intelligence he would have figured
this out pretty quickly but one of the
things to remember about Reed Richards
of the Fantastic Four is he's very
rarely ever concerned about what goes on
with Earth because you have so many
superhero groups that are there so if
there is some kind of a major threat the
Fantastic Four will get involved but in
Marvel Comics in terms of Fantastic Four
stories that have been published for the
longest time they've been the
space-faring Multiverse exploring team
right that's kind of their Frontier
that's where they focus on things
because dealing with Earth is Small Time
stuff they've done that dance they've
done their dirt they've served their
time
and so what ends up happening here is
realizing that the different members of
the Fantastic Four all have their
strengths and weaknesses Ben Grimm is
the one who's the most easily overtaken
by the X-Men and he is it allows him to
revert to his human form and then in
turn the the Fantastic Four are kind of
sent on a false Mission by the X-Men and
by Ben Grimm and during that mission the
X-Men actually helped Ben Grim to devise
a scheme whereby the other members of
the Fantastic Four are all turned into
Ben Grims he in turn strangles them all
to death and that's the end of them and
so following that with Captain America
under control of the X-Men he in turn
strikes at the White House takes out the
president and then what the X-Men do is
they attack The Avengers because at this
point all the Avengers have all been
taken over so with the Avengers
launching an attack against the US
government the X-Men step in they defeat
the Avengers and they're hailed as
Heroes that's the beauty of this is
literally they kept pushing the Avengers
to do these more and more extreme tasks
so by the time time they launched an
attack against the White House the
general population who hadn't been taken
over and wasn't aware that this takeover
was happening would kind of be like yeah
I guess it was only a matter of time
before the Avengers did something crazy
like that thank God the X-Men saved us
that's the idea that's the motivation so
the X-Men are hailed as Heroes of the
world now the cool thing here is we jump
forward five years right we pick up in
year five everything we've talked about
so far is in is within one year it's a
one-year span right one year into the
future so five years into the future
storm arrives and storm of course is the
leader of the Iraqi they have the whole
they have their whole history and
everything but basically they are a
massive group of mutants that we didn't
know existed until Jonathan Hickman
started writing the X-Men they initially
existed in another dimension but once
they ended up arriving in the main
Marvel Universe they took up residence
on Mars and they formed their own
government storm eventually became the
leader of that Circle right that's what
they call their governing body on uh on
Mars and it's just kind of been
operating as their leader ever since but
with with all of this happening storm is
watching everything taking place and
she's realizing how extreme the X-Men
are becoming and the kind of battles
they're getting into and she's not
trusting them more so than that what she
realizes is that the Nightcrawler that's
currently there is not the actual
Nightcrawler he's an impersonator and so
when she asks the question where is the
real Nightcrawler that's when Sinister
presents himself now one thing to know
is that storm was not on the quantity or
at least was on the quiet Council when
Sinister was locked away but she didn't
know that everybody else was being taken
over by the Sinister Gene so to the
Lasser to the best of her knowledge
sinisters in the pit that's where he's
supposed to be she doesn't know that he
was released by The X-Men and so
literally she's like okay uh why is he
here right he's supposed to be in the
pit not only that when he does reappear
what he shows is that he's been
tampering with the genes of Nightcrawler
and turned him into this kind of
grotesque beast and so he's like the
Nightcrawler that's been with you is the
one that I created so I could tamper
with the real night crawler up his jeans
and you would never know the difference
so you got an option either you can deal
with this puppet that I have installed
and you can just kind of go from there
you can join our cause or we can take
you out and so what ends up happening is
that with storm and one of the reasons
why she was able to avoid all this is
incredibly simple so what Sinister had
been doing when it came to him taking
over and everybody being infiltrated
what Sinister had done is he had
modified the resurrection machine and
what would happen is that every time a
mutant was killed and resurrected they
would be secretly infected with the
Sinister Gene that's how he was able to
take everybody over storm was not
infected by that because if you guys
remember during Judgment Day storm got
rid of her of her backup in the
resurrection protocols so that if she
dies she stays dead there's no
conceivable way of bringing her back
Magneto also did the same thing and so
the result of this is that storm is not
infected because she hasn't been
resurrected since the tampering was done
by Mr Sinister and so in response to
that because they can't simply just kill
her because ultimately if the quiet
Council killed storm it would ultimately
result in a civil war because she's so
respected by mutants on both sides
especially the ones that haven't been
taken over yet and so what ends up
happening is that Professor Xavier and
Emma Frost used their telepathy to try
to control the mind of storm and so what
we end up doing is transitioning back or
kind of jumping back to a bit of a
flashback when storm is meeting with
laktuka I think is how you pronounce
their name but latuka is basically a
member of the great Ring of Oracle right
the governing body of Mars basically and
everybody on the governing body of Mars
is an Omega Level mutant which of course
means that there are some of the most
powerful mutants in existence with
lactica or laktuka however you pronounce
it that basically they have the ability
to know everything that's going on right
just Universal maybe even multiversal
awareness but more so than that they
house like an infinite number of minds
and the result of this is that when they
basically back up the mind of of storm
what it means is that when Xavier and
Emma Frost launched their telepathic
attack it's not just trying to take over
the mind of storm is trying to take over
an infinite number of Minds at the same
time which of course they can't do it's
one person standing on a beach trying to
hold back a tidal wave that's 300 feet
tall and 500 feet wide right it's not
gonna happen you know what I mean you're
just going to be engulfed by that thing
and that's going to be the end of you
and so this basically allows storm to go
without being infected by Xavier and
Emma Frost she cast down this amazing
lightning bolt and she's just like
Abominations right imposters and then
takes off right literally just leaves
and so that's when she comes to the
realization This Is War right that's
basically what this is this is now a
civil war among the mutants those who
are infected and those who were not now
the cool thing about this is that as
storm makes me like if she literally
make readies her forces she's met by the
arrival of Destiny and Mystique remember
Destiny can see the future she's a
precog it's not all in stone so if
Destiny comes to you and says this is
going to happen in five minutes it's the
absolute truth if she comes to you and
says this is going to happen in five
years it may or may not happen because a
lot of things can take place between now
and five years so again it's not an
absolute prediction but she is the most
trusted precog that's out there but she
tells storm if you go and attack the
X-Men now you are guaranteed to lose we
have to abide our time we have to wait
and so the result of this is that we
transition to essentially Sebastian Shaw
of the hellfire club now Sebastian Shaw
has been kind of a background character
for quite some time but he becomes an
emissary to the Realms of hell right to
the Realms of limbo but what this does
is it allows the X-Men to conquer all
the different hell Realms right the
Realms of Mephisto and all those
different guys beyond that you have
magic who actually or at least Ileana
Rasputin who ends up making a deal on
behalf of the X-Men with Serta from
muspelheim because what had happened is
that when the Avengers became more and
more extreme leading up to them
attacking the U.S government Thor
ultimately vacated he abandoned The
Avengers heartbroken and ended up just
residing in uh in Asgard and staying
there seemingly permanently but with
magic making a deal with certa in order
to destroy Asgard she gets the Twilight
sword which is literally the sword of
Ragnarok right like that's the source a
sword sort of would use to wipe out
everything in Asgard she shows up here
using her magical abilities and destroys
Asgard and the asgardians are cast out
into the abyss never to be seen or heard
from again on top of that Sinister and
the X-Men they wipe out Juan to maximoff
right they destroy the Scarlet Witch
because remember during the events of
House of M leading up to House of M she
had the ability to alter reality on a
universal scale she could set everything
back and so what ends up happening
during this time is that Sinister right
it's like you know continuing to skip
forward through time Sinister ends up
using the Westchester Institute the
Xavier school for gifted youngsters as a
gigantic lab and he literally starts
splicing together the genes of different
mutants into like a singular body so you
might have like the genes of Colossus
that are merged with the genes of
nightcrawlers so you have like night
Colossus which is kind of an awesome
name if I'm being honest with you guys
right okay so here's what here's what I
want you guys to do here's what I want
you guys to do leave a comment down
below with like spliced names right so
like if you were gonna merge like
Wolverine and cyclops or like if you
were gonna if you're gonna name the
merger of like Nightcrawler and Colossus
give me those names man because I really
want to see them right I think it would
be awesome but using these splice jeans
what it does is it allows the X-Men to
become more powerful than they ever were
before because now they possess multiple
Powers so an army composed of 100 X-Men
suddenly becomes what is in effect 200
X-Men because each one of those X-Men
now has two Powers 100 times 2 is 200 so
literally that's one of the crazy things
because when that happens an attack is
launched by Sinister the X-Men and all
those guys against the forces of storm
right all those guys out there and so
what we end up doing is jumping forward
10 years and what we end up finding out
here is that the human population is by
and large aware of what's going on but
they don't care right they realize like
they want to be a part of this greater
thing that Sinister has kind of created
the peaceful coexistence between humans
and mutants but he's done it in a
nefarious way he's done it through mind
control right he's done it through
conquering and all that kind of stuff
it's kind of nuts and so what we end up
doing is basically picking up during
this 10-year time Jump when Sinister is
meeting with the Quiet Council and the
quiet Council actually reveals that what
they've been doing is modifying the
programming of the Sinister Gene in each
one of themselves so they don't operate
as a slave of Mr Sinister instead they
operate as their own individual person
doing their own individual thing they
still operate under the guise or at
least still operate with the idea of the
X-Men conquering everything but they're
not like dogs on a leash for sinister
you know what I mean but in effect this
leads Sinister to realize he's lost
control of the people that he's supposed
to be in controlling he's lost control
of the Kawaii Council they have too much
free will and so what his intention is
is to basically go back and wipe the
entire project right literally wipe them
all out and that'll basically be it and
then effectively start over the issue is
that once he gets back there he realizes
the entirety of his lab is gone his
ability to rework this whole process
doesn't exist anymore someone's stolen
his lap and so in effect he's now
trapped down here there's no conceivable
means for him to escape so he literally
loses control of his own project he
always ends up losing here and that's
where it sends a Sinister Leaf let me
know okay okay do we need to cover the
rest of this because it's not completely
done yet right like it's still coming
out on a monthly basis so I don't know
exactly how long it'll take to finish
but like do we need to cover this man
because honestly this story is dope it's
one of the most interesting stories I've
seen with the X-Men in so long let me
know what you guys think right but thank
you all for watching and I will catch
you all later
peace